that's getting hotter yeah definitely um
that's the transition i feel like
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by malcolm gladwell
he's the author of five new york times
bestselling books including the tipping
point blink and outliers his latest
though is the bomber mafia which is out
now and more good news for malcolm
gladwell fans his massively popular
podcast revisionist history returns june
24th
malcolm gladwell welcome to the show
thank you i've seen your deep dive on
tomato sauce before
how deeply have you explored the world
of hot sauce i would say on this
range here i'm probably comfortable down
here
so i'm uh i'm in the 20th percentile
and that's not a place i'd like to be
right now
[Music]
okay
no uh i seem to be okay so far
[Music]
so i think in part because of your
brilliance and packaging them you know
some of your writing whether it's the
ten thousand hour rule or phrases like
tipping point or maven
they've developed such a cultural
currency that they get used by people
who probably
haven't read your books and might not
even know who you are do you have
a misapplication of malcolm gladwell
that annoys you the most
well i mean why would you be annoyed
even if somebody
is getting you wrong they're still
getting you right
one of my favorite things is remember
the book for economics
for some reason everyone thought that
you were i wrote for economics
at the beginning i would say no no you
don't i didn't write that book that was
stephen dubner and steven levitt
and then after a while i was like you
know what why am i fighting this so now
it just happened a couple years ago some
guy said i love your books man
freakonomics and i was like yeah
i don't find it anymore
that one's quite nice actually you know
would be a really cool trick by the way
is to mix up the order so you tell me
it's going from mild to spicy
but then you put the spiciest one at the
beginning and i'm like oh my god like
this is gonna get worse from here right
or like a russian roulette where it's
like randomized or yeah but you can't
if you don't tell me then i'm gonna get
we don't do that we don't play that game
well that's what you would say if you
did that's how you would perpetuate
the fraud on me yeah that is true so i
know that you've been a runner your
whole life and there are some world
records and distance running that hold
for decades and others like the marathon
that seem to get broken
every few years is someone who's thought
a lot about the optimal conditions for
human achievement
what do you make of sports records that
are broken even though there's no
rule change or technological
breakthrough to drive improvement
well you know there is this thing i mean
it's well remarked thing it was observed
after
roger bannister broke the four-minute
mile back in 1954
um which is there was a psychological
barrier there and once we were aware
that
oh you know a very nice medical student
from
oxford england can run a four minute
mile lots of other people realize they
could do it
there's a similar thing um going on
right now in japan where
the times coming out of japan and the 10
000 meters in the marathon
are crazy but it's near it's not that
the fastest person is super fast
is that insane numbers of people are
running
like one tiny bit below the fastest in
the world
they just have numbers that we've never
seen before at that level and that's
just that's clearly there's some element
of psychology there that
lots of people realize well i can this
is something i can do
and then of course we're approaching the
summer olympics you know that time the
one time every four years that track and
field gets thrust into the mainstream
spotlight
what to use the most fascinating
distance race and why
i would say the 5 000 meters now no one
except for serious runners things the
5000 meters is interesting
but it's like the first 10 minutes of
that nothing happens
and you're waiting and waiting and
waiting and waiting and waiting and then
somebody
pounces right they're all exhausted
they've all been playing these micro
games for
10 11 minutes and then all of the kind
of
in a rush like in a horror film like the
ending just goes wow like that's what
happens in the
fight so you spend i get almost sick to
my stomach like
waiting in anticipation for the first
person to pounce
speaking of sick to my stomach
appropriately i should bring that up
all right tommaso it says
intensely spicy i guess it was intensely
spicy i'm going to
accept their verdict on that
now i'm wondering does my mouth get
numbed
we put these sauces together as a way to
make that kind of reaction symphony
so i see you it's very deep it's very
deep malcolm
there's a science behind the torture
yeah exactly did you ever did you ever
have someone from the cia
on and they could compare you guys could
compare notes on
your different strategies of torturing
people no but i'm taking mental notes of
all of this stuff malcolm
always thinking about how we can advance
the concept here in the past we've asked
guests if they think
memes are art with you i'm curious do
you think that memes are
good tools of communication they're not
i wouldn't call them
art memes are a response to the demands
of
social media like you have this
opportunity
not just to say something but to show
something and also to reference
popular culture in some way to like
build on the shared experience of the
people who will read that
bit of social media so there's very very
very clever response to those
set of constraints um all storytelling
good storytelling
is is exactly that like why are we so
interested in audiobooks it's a response
to
the fact that people now go around with
things in their ears and it's like well
how can i tell them a story in that
moment the answer is i'm going to tell a
story through their phone
so you know unlike most books barbara
mafia was conceived of as an audiobook
so from the very beginning i said i want
to tell a story
through sound so it's a story about the
second world war but we have tape of all
these guys interviews with all these
players we have you know radio clips
from the 40s we have
documentaries we can wartime
documentaries we can pull from
so when i describe a battle an air
battle or something
i can i can bring it to life when i talk
there's a character in the book called
curtis lemay
you have to hear him he kind of has this
guttural grunting
way of talking you're like oh yes this
guy is ferocious
bona mafi was a response to the fact
that i can take you back to
the air wars of the 1940s and just make
you care about them like that's what
we're trying to do
seems like the one before maybe i'm
speaking too soon is this one is this a
is this a late hitter i think we're
still in a comfortable zone and malcolm
by my math we've already done
one full lap around any expectation you
had for yourself so
uh yeah yeah but i know you you like
you're stacking look at these ones i
mean
i have no illusions you're just
softening me up for the kill that's all
this is
no no i'd never do that to you malcolm
i've never said i'd never set you up
like that
so in a 2005 new yorker column titled
brain candy you muse about stephen
johnson's
theory that video games like grand theft
auto 3 may be undervalued and their
ability to sharpen certain cognitive
skills
where do you fall on that like do you
think kids may be
better off playing more grand theft auto
and doing less homework
no no he was pointing at something
that's um
one of the most interesting and um
puzzling
phenomenon in social science is that
iqs had been rising pretty steadily over
the last 10
hundred years so your iq is absolutely
higher than
the iq of your parents and their iq is
higher than their parents
and your grandparents iq is higher than
your great-grandparents iq
it's not because you are inherently
smarter it's that every generation seems
to be getting smarter we don't know why
but there's certain kinds of abstract
reasoning things where we're a lot
better
conceptualizing problems and pulling out
principles
imagining scenarios and johnson's
argument was that
maybe some of that is video games video
games do force you to make predictions
about what's happening to look at data
and combine data you think about it i
mean you're constantly thinking about
what do i need to do next and
you're not making a random guess you're
making an intelligent choice
so he said it's a kind of cognitive
practice that would make you
smarter and if you had an entire
generation of people
who are doing lots of these video games
they're going to be better at this kind
of rapid
data analysis essentially but when i was
a kid i played a ton of risk
forming alliances and learning how to
persuade people to go along with you
and trying to figure out what's going to
happen two and three moves ahead
i think games in general are a hugely
important
educational tool
now it's funny i'm mildly allergic to
pineapple i notice it's pineapple and
ginger
oh we have reapers in here we have
scorpion peppers we have all this stuff
the one that we really need to worry
about is the pineapple who knew yeah no
my immune system will quickly i think be
overwhelmed with other bigger concerns
so soon enough malcolm all right malcolm
we have a recurring segment on our show
called explain that graham we're doing a
deep dive on our guest instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
contacts
so we'll show you the picture on the
monitor you just tell us the bigger
story
you know there are some really first
class i don't know if they're on my
instagram though
um there's one of me with david
hasselhoff oh
is there there it is
there it is me and the hoff the thing i
love about this picture
is i have never looked so happy
i am so delighted with myself i'm on a
talk show in sweden
and in sweden the hof is a kind of i
mean he's god
i mean he's like he's not he's you know
as a he's on a level of celebrity that
we can't even glimpse
and i was just so tickled pink to be on
the same
you know talk show sitting next to the
hof the whole time
and he's enormously charming as you can
imagine
the swedish were much more reverential
towards him than
americans might have been which created
a very interesting dynamic
anyway by the end of the evening i was
just beside myself
with the thrill of this moment and all i
could think of is oh my god
like i just i need the world to see me
with the huff
it just needs to happen
all right
[Music]
that's getting hotter yeah definitely um
that's the transition i feel like this
is a
quote of yours that i love and i'm just
wondering if you could expand on it
critics take a more meta position that
isn't reflective of the audience
sometimes i think when i read criticism
of not
just my work but of any lots of people's
works is that
the mistake critics make is they assume
the audience is dumb
i don't never said why they assume that
i consume things all the time
where i disagree with the writer but i'm
fine with that because i'm
learning i'm learning about the writer
i'm learning about the world i'm
learning
i'm being forced to kind of justify my
own positions or i'm just being
entertained
right like those are all legit reasons
to read a book or listen to a podcast or
listen to it
and critics sometimes assume that if you
aren't feeding your audience some kind
of
simple coherent um uh
uh easy to digest line you're doing them
some kind of a disservice
it's just not just nonsense people the
one thing people are not
is dumb
oh god this one i'm just smelling it
i'm seeing psyching yourself out a
little bit i'm just kidding
so most people probably know you from
your new yorker articles or your
best-selling books but for me
i became a fan from your work your
sports takes on the curious guy
column on espn's page two with bill
simmons
can you enlighten our audience on why
you believe that brett favre
is more likely to make mistakes during a
fourth quarter comeback than joe montana
or tom brady
i am obsessed with heart rates they are
an
under uh appreciated predictor of a
wide range of human behaviors when you
have these people who are forced to
perform under pressure
the ones who really excel very often
they're just lucky enough to have really
really low heart rates
so i suspected that the tom brady's of
the world have lower resting heart rates
than the bret farms of the world
is there anything that intrigues you
about this bizarre last year of
athletic competition like maybe how 13
year olds missing this year of
development how that might affect the
nba draft and
nine years or anything like that i
wonder whether there'll be a good thing
i feel very differently about academic
preparation by the way but athletic
preparation
it's not just a bad thing you know i
read something about
someone was doing um scans of the
tendons of kids coming into the nba
and their knees looked like the knees of
30 year olds because it played so much
ball
the mileage yeah the mileage is just too
much i think it's i think
probably should call a halt to that a
little bit
let's do this
[Music]
that's pretty uh it's pretty nasty
um yeah um yeah that's that's like a
my father would say it's quite hot
[Laughter]
so you've shared a lot of thoughts on
the workplace whether it's a podcast
about hiring assistants or debating
the merit or lack thereof and
traditional job interviews so what i
want to do
is hit you with a few commonplace
workplace aphorisms
and i'm just curious how they hit your
ear as somebody who oftentimes
has a contrarian point of view on these
sorts of things yeah
from guy kawasaki my theory is that a
players hire people even better than
themselves
it's clear though that b players hire c
players so they can feel
superior to them if you start hiring b
players
expect the bozo explosion to happen at
your organization
are people who are mediocre afraid of
being shown up
i think i guess sometimes but most
bosses i've worked for in the past
are like parents they're like if someone
who works with them is a
genius they're just the happiest people
in the world they're like constantly
jumping down about you know just so you
have no idea this kid's so smart like
that's what i hear
i never hear oh my god this kid's so
smart and it's bumming me out like he
says that what kind of boss says that
i have the best assistant in the world
and i hate her right now no one does
that that's
nuts all right this one's from simon and
garfunkel
fake it till you make it you know is
there room in life for a little bit of
deception from time to time sure you
never know and again
there'll be something about
someone lied on their resume
i feel like that's the smallest possible
crime
i had that episode of my podcast on
hiring and i said i don't like to
i don't like to know where my people i
hired went to college
that's my response to that problem you
don't have to hire you don't have to lie
on your resume
when you apply for a job with me because
i'm not looking at it
you can say what you want you can say
you did your phd on the moon
i'm not going to see it so you know
knock yourself out
one more for you statistics are like a
lamp post to a drunken man
more for leaning on than illumination
that's from david brent
well come on depends on the statistic if
i asked your previous boss to rate you
on a scale of one to ten
that's a statistic is that meaningful
probably yeah
i wouldn't mind knowing that number um
so it depends i guess it was
you're now on to the number nine sauce
how are you feeling
okay scorpion disco is not an
encouraging
label no we've reached that point in the
uh
in the interview where they're all just
all right
this sauce is from rochester new york
i'm sorry that lacks credibility
where's the huts oh there we are
shouldn't have scorpion
i see but as someone you know who has is
a partial jamaican heritage
a big uh commonly used pepper in the is
uh the scotch bonnet do you ever have
like so
yes i have scotch bonnets in my
refrigerator um
we freeze them and then we but you have
to be very careful because
most people can't tolerate them right
but
but but you you you put yourself in 20
percentile but here you are freezing
scotch bonnets and stuff
yeah i'm using like a tiniest bit i mean
i'm exercising stream my favorite
expression about i exercise an abundance
of caution
when it comes to scotching on scotch pan
and bonnets
so two of my favorite case studies in
the tipping point
are the resurgence of hush puppies and
then the rise and fall of
airwalk as like a cool kid brand and it
really had me
thinking about sneaker hype today which
is absolutely
exploded and now the coolest sneakers
are oftentimes
these limited releases that get bought
up by bots online and then sold in the
secondary market at like
2 5 10 15 20 times what they cost in
stores
is that tenable i think people have
gotten really smart about managing
that marketplace and keeping it intimate
and
i mean no one's trying to blow these
sneakers out and make a million
pairs um they understand i think
i think people have gotten a lot smarter
about how to manage these little kind of
you know these little niche things that
people do or that nike occasionally will
do like a
you know some air jordan thingy or
whatever have you but those are
incompatible
approaches um and i you know i often
think about this with my books
that uh people who write books like mine
have the same decision to make
who you what are you trying to do are
you trying to appeal to
a very narrow band of specialists or are
you trying to
appeal to um the the kind of
the casual reader and that's a choice
that conditions a lot of decisions that
you make in how you tell the story how
you write the book
and you can't please both groups right
got to pick all right malcolm gladwell
it's that time
so this is the last dab we call it the
last dab because it's tradition around
here to put a little extra
on the last wing you don't have to if
you don't want to wait you just
piled it on i'm a little out of practice
you know this is uh
i don't know where it airs in the season
but this is the first shoot that we've
had back in the studio since justin
timberlake
more than 12 months ago so i think i'm
just a little out of practice but um
you don't have to do this i thought this
is where i'm going to get my comeuppance
i'm going to kind of collapse
you look like you're sweating and you're
distressed
somewhat somewhat
[Music]
all right malcolm gladwell we have
slayed the hot sauce goliath but before
we get you on your way just one more
question
you've been consistent about your
willingness to be inconsistent and
change your mind and i love this quote
the older i get the more i understand
that the only way to say valuable things
is to lose your fear of being correct
what do you feel is your biggest most
meaningful flip-flop to date
oh my god probably my most meaningful
flip-flops are on
people in fact a number of my friends
are people who i did not meet up on did
not like upon first meeting
um and that's been and that
the trick there is super simple which is
you meet someone you don't like them
just don't say anything
don't tell anyone don't tell them just
smile
and then go home and think about it and
then meet them again and
start from zero um and once you know
that
all i know is that my first impressions
people are just really terrible
so i just throw that out i mean just
throw that out like not helpful
malcolm gladwell walks in
20 looking at you from across the table
putting me to shame
taking on the wings of death and living
to tell the story and now malcolm
gladwell there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you
this camera that camera that camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life
i have uh a book that has just come out
called the bomber mafia which is
an incredible i think audiobook which
you can get at
the borah mafia buddy bombermafia.com
and then i have my new season of
revisions history coming up june
24th so lots of things in the hopper i
hope you're okay
a little concerned about you over there
but sleeping off
maybe next time you'll have a better
experience
great job nelson great job
[Applause]
i think the pineapple actually is the
thing that anything that threw me for a
loop but uh
my mouth just got numb and so i just
stopped tasting anything
my my nerve endings just got all
dulled it's quite hard
hey what's going on everybody this is
sean evans checking in with some very
exciting first week feast news
now when i'm not over here choking down
chicken wings on hot ones
i happen to be a huge pizza guy sicilian
neapolitan deep dish dollar slice
frozen pizza i love it all which is why
i'm excited to announce that first we
feast has a brand new show
pizza wars where pizza master nicole
russell takes on contenders in a battle
royale of different pizza styles
i'm on there judging the deep dish
episode naturally but the show has other
great guests as well including buddies
like babish and frank pinello but that's
enough chit chat let's let the sizzle
reel do the talking
alright roll the tape
the misconception is that if you get a
lot it's good
bite for bite this is the best eating
experience i've ever had on one of these
things
my opponents and i will be taking on a
new pizza themed challenge
every episode i wish that i could give
you both trophies but they only gave me
one you guys have an extra
they don't have an extra don't get it
twisted this is a competition and i want
to win
but i'm also here to catch up with a few
of my friends i couldn't have done this
episode with nobody else
to learn some new tricks to use at home
you gotta slice the garlic thin
so thin that it liquefies in the pan no
no thank you for that
thank you nona i eat a whole bunch of
pizza
oh my god
so get ready people peace awards is
coming
[Music]
you